numerical linear
algebra thank you
Howard um so I'm going to discuss one of
the simplest ways to basically create a
succinct sketch of a
matrix and that way would be to apply a
simple sampling algorithm and pick a few
let's say rows but we'll do the same
with columns pick a few rows from The
Matrix and just keep those rows so the
objective will be take the Matrix H an M
byn Matrix and summarize it summarize it
by keeping only a few of each rows to
create this smaller R byn Matrix and the
sampling algorithm we're going to use is
going to be this three liner here the
input is an N byn Matrix a and the
sampling parameter R indicating how many
rows of a we're going to keep and what
we're going to do is we are going to fix
a probability distribution we're going
to compute a probability distribution
over the rows of a P1 up to p subm and
we're going to sample in I IID trials
independent identically distributed that
makes our life in analysis much easier
uh we're going to sample with
replacement so we could sample the same
row multiple times again this is because
it makes our analysis much easier are
rows of a where in each trial a
particular row is picked with
probability Pi in order to get unbiased
estimators it's a good idea whenever you
sample a row to actually keep a
rescaling factor as well so you sample a
row you rescale it as well and you
rescale it by something like one over
the square root of R * pi r is the
sampling is is is the sampling parameter
how many rows you are going to keep p is
the probability with which you sample
that particular row this helps in the
analysis to get unbiased estimators but
the idea is you sketch your Matrix
simply by keeping a few of each rows and
you keep the rows by randomly sampling
them of course what I'm not revealing
just yet is what are the appropriate
sampling probabilities and that we are
going to be discussing throughout the
column sampling would be the same except
instead of doing it on the Matrix a
you're going to do it on a transpose so
now if you sample rows of a transpose
you're are sampling Columns of a so row
and column sampling they can both be
treated within this very simple
framework this prototypical algorithm
that I'm going to be discussing
throughout the
talk and the question is what are good
choices for sampling probabilities and
about 15 years ago the proposal that uh
appeared actually in a paper by Alan fre
an and Santos vampa and then in another
paper the next year that I was also
involved in uh was to use the so-called
length squared sampling so you're going
to sample rows of the Matrix with
probability proportional to their ukian
Norms the square actually of their ukian
Norms the ukian norm of a row is the sum
of the squares of the entries so
basically you are biasing yourself
towards rows of a that have larger
entries if your Matrix is a 01 Matrix
then you are biasing yourself towards
row both of the Matrix that have more
nonzero entries and that's a good idea
because that's where the action
basically happens okay so that's a very
simple probability distribution very
easy to compute just make a pass through
your Matrix and you are done and what
does it it has been of course explored a
lot uh in the literature over the past
15 years and it leads to what in the
parlance of this morning stocks would be
additive error approximations so it's
going to lead to approximations for
things like the singular value the
composition of a matrix approximating
Left Right singular Vector singular
values but up to additive errors which
again might or might not be sufficient
for your applications it's going to lead
to additive error approximations for
things like the C and CX factorization
I'll talk about the CX factorization
later it's going to lead to additive ER
approximation for something that
statisticians and machine Learners are
more interested in in kernal matrices
the NR method and so on and so forth you
want to move Beyond so you want to have
better probability distributions that
basically get more accuracy when you try
to sketch your Matrix one such
probability distribution is the leverage
course and Michael Mahone this morning
already mentioned that but I'm going to
go into a lot more detail throughout the
talk and the idea here is the following
instead of doing length Square sampling
on the row of the Matrix you compute
your probability distribution looking at
the top K left singular vectors of the
Matrix so let me explain this with a
picture you still sample from a you are
still going to keep rows of a that
doesn't change what changes is how you
compute your probability distribution
and what you do is you compute the top K
left singular vectors of the Matrix and
you look at the length squares at the
ukian Norms squared of the rows of this
m by K Matrix U subk so that's what you
use to compute your probabilities your
sampling probabilities for rows of a you
don't use a directly you compute the top
K left singular vectors and you use the
rows of u k to compute your
probabilities Remember The Columns of U
subk are pairwise orthogonal and normal
so the columns you know a lot about the
rows not so much all you can say is that
the ukian Norms are between Z and one
okay so you use those ukian Norms
squared of the row of U subk to form
your probability distribution it looks
like there is an extra parameter K here
which you have to take into account in
all the application of the leverage
scores this parameter K will not
basically be a free parameter it will be
directly set by the formulation of the
problem and we'll see a number of
applications so hopefully that's going
to become clear for now it looks like a
free parameter it's really
not this leads if you are willing to
sample with respect to those much more
carefully constructed sampling
probabilities and we'll see how long it
takes and so on so forth to construct
them you're going to get relative error
approximations for a bunch of problem s
for which previously you could only get
additive error approximations so you're
going to get relative error
approximations to things like for
example the top K left and right
singular vectors of a matrix actually
the Subspace span by those you're going
to get relative error approximations for
CCX over and under constraint Le squares
problems I'm going to discuss that you
can get relative error approximations to
solving over constraint or under
constraint Le squares problems
interestingly you can also look at
solving systems of linear equations the
special case of laian matrices though
we'll get to that as well and you can
get very good approximations there as
well by sampling with respect to
leverage
CES and of course I'm talking about row
sampling here you could do column
sampling and column sampling same story
instead of working on a work on a
transpose now the left singular vectors
of a transpose are the right singular
vectors of a so if you want to do column
sampling you are basically looking at
the top K right singular vectors of a
very often denoted the NN by K Matrix V
subk okay so two probability
distributions you can do length Square
sampling directly on The Matrix a or you
can compute the top K left singular
vectors let's say of a and do length
squared sampling looking at that Matrix
U
subk and those are the leverage scores
let's see a few examples that are going
to come again and again one particular
example is the case of a tall and thin
Matrix this is a matrix that is n by D
with n now considerably larger let's say
than d think that n is at least D log D
and
more then the SVD the singular value the
composition of a can be expressed as
follows U Sigma V transpose let's assume
full rank just to make our life simpler
everything generalizes but if you assume
full rank then this is going to be a
rotation Sigma is going to be a diagonal
matrix um and all the entries there are
going to be actually strictly greater
than zero all the singular values are
going to be strictly positive and U this
is the Matrix where the ction happens
this is going to be the Matrix of the
left singular vectors all of them in
this particular case the parameter K
will be D so we're going to look at the
full rank of the Matrix so there is no
free parameter K anymore and the r
average scores are going to be the ukian
Norms of the the Idan Norm squared of
the of the of the row of you okay so
that's the case of a toall thin Matrix
now you could sample with respect to
this R average scores and create a
sketch of a that's exactly what we're
going to do in the case of over
constrained uh Le squares
problems you could have sort of the
symmetric case where a now is D byn and
now you have D again much smaller than n
this is sort of a short and fat
Matrix U is now a rotation assuming full
rank Sigma is a diagonal matrix all the
entri is strictly greater than zero all
the entes in the diagonal strictly
greater than zero V transpose is where
the action happens now V the rows of V
transpose are pairwise orthogonal and
normal you don't know much about the
columns and it is exactly those ukian
Norms squared of The Columns of V
transpose that you want to use as your
sampling probabilities this could be the
design Matrix in an under constraint Le
squares problem where you now have a
small number of constraints large number
of variables you could use those
sampling probabilities The Leverage
scores the column leverage scores to
sample a few Columns of a create a
sketch of a and you could use that to
solve an under constraint Le squares
problem as opposed to the full
Matrix again no free parameter k k is
going to be set to just be the rank of
the
Matrix and of course the sort of square
case the case where a is an M byn Matrix
where now M and N are comparable in this
case the action happens at a rank K
approximation to a in order to Define
The Leverage course you look at a rank K
approximation to a
this Matrix a subk which can be
expressed from the singular value the
composition as top K left singular
vectors corresponding singular values
top K right singular
vectors so now basically you moved from
the Matrix a to a low rank approximation
to a and in this case I use the best low
rank approximation to a but you could
Define actually leverage scores with
respect to any low rank approximation to
a not necessarily the best one the SVD
Returns the rank a approximation that is
as close to a as possible with respect
to any unitarily invariant Norm but you
could use slightly worse you would still
get leverage scores and actually that's
going to be a way to approximate
leverage scores Downstream and in this
case you have raow leverage scores if
you look at U subk the ukian Norms of
the row of U subk you could have column
leverage scores if you look at the ukian
Norms of The Columns of VK transpose and
you could subsample rows or columns or
potentially or potentially rows and
Columns of the Matrix to create a
sketch so that's the notion of Leverage
scores in the three cases that basically
cover all possible cases tall and thin
short and fat and roughly Square
matrices this is not the only way to
sketch a matrix of course it's a very
simple way you keep a subset of the rows
or columns from a matrix but there are
many other ways as a matter of fact if
you want to keep row and columns from a
matrix you could use a volume sampling
approach where you are trying to pick a
subset of Ross and CS of a matrix that
span a parallel piped of large volume
and that's an approach that actually I
made the span that we talk about
tomorrow you could use random
projections and that's the stuff that
Michael Mahoney was talking about this
morning you can use gaussians to sketch
your Matrix and this is slow you can use
things like the hadamar transformer
forier Matrix with randomization to get
faster sketches you could use the
sparsity stuff what uh Michael and
zriang and Ken Clark and David Wu have
been developing over the past uh year to
get even better results there are
deterministic ways to pick a subset of
rows and columns from a matrix that
actually are quite accurate and I think
nastava will talk a little bit about
that in the context of graph
specification uh Ido Liberty who should
be talking right after me will be
talking about uh uh using streaming type
ideas uh to get very fast very accurate
sketches of a
matrix and of course you don't have to
think about just sampling rows and
columns from a matrix you could just
sample elements and get a sketch of a
matrix by keeping a few elements from
The Matrix not necessarily full rows and
columns and that's something that
actually leverage scores even there will
help hopefully we'll get to that at the
end of the talk and finally you could
also move Beyond matrices so matrices
are basically two dimensional arrays
there is no reason to just think that
this is the end of the story you could
have three four Etc dimensional arrays
those are often called tensors a lot of
things become much harder there for
example just tensor rank a natural
definition of tensor rank is EMP hard to
comp comput the tensor rank whereas of
course in matrices we know very well how
to do those things and Ravi Canan will
be talking about some um what happens
when you move from The Matrix land to
tensor
land so I'm going to talk about a bunch
of applications of the leverage course
and those are going to be applications
to solving over or under constraint Le
squares problems doing feature selection
in real data and that's going to be
connected to six factorization looking
at Sol the solution of systems of linear
equations and the special the very
special case where the input Matrix is a
laian matrix so it corresponds to a
graph moving beyond graphs seems to be
quite a difficult challenge at this
point and finally connections between
leverage scores and basically element y
sampl before that let me address two
other issues I'm not going to get too
technical in the talk uh but I want to
show why leverage scores work what is at
the heart of all the proofs that involve
leverage scores and I want to talk a
little bit about running time because
because it's not obvious how long it
takes to compute those you can do it in
a naive way via the SVD but there are
much better ways to do
it all the proofs that I know of that
use leverage scores at some point use
the following
argument think of now a toll and thin
Matrix U but now U is orthogonal so The
Columns of U are pairwise orthogonal and
normal in particular U transpose U is
the
identity if you subsample U using the
Leverage course so you keep a few rows
of you instead of keeping an N byd
Matrix you move to an R byd Matrix we'll
see how large R has to be to create a
matrix U Tilda so you keep a few rows of
U you rescale them as well just like we
discussed in the second slide and you
form this Matrix utia it turns out that
you can prove the following you can
prove that the spectral Norm of U
transpose U minus ulda transpose ulda so
the exact product of U transpose time U
versus the approximate product utia
transpose time utia is less than or
equal to Epsilon for any Epsilon as long
as you sample enough and Sample enough
think of Epsilon being a constant one
over 100 sample enough means order dlog
D rows so if you sample enough youu can
be compressed to be this Matrix utia and
now U Tilda satisfies this property here
which implies that all the singular
values of ulda are close to one
so basically you start with an
orthogonal Matrix you down sample you
still have an almost orthogonal Matrix
that's basically um at the heart of any
proof that involves leverage scores this
is actually it used to be a fairly hard
result to prove but recently with uh the
the enormous project that progress that
has been made on Matrix chernof and
Matrix Burnstein bounds this is
basically a very simple application of
such bounds and and for those of you who
are not here for the boot camp Michael
Mahoney and I as well as Joel trop gave
tutorials Joel discussed the Matrix CH
of B Matrix bnst inequalities we
discussed how matrix multiplication
implies this kind of result so take a
look there to see the exact connections
between this measure concentration
results and approximate matrix
multiplication and at the end of the day
this allows us to manipulate the pseudo
inverse of utia because utia is
approximately orthogonal it's pseudo
inverse generalization of the inverse to
matrices that are not square or matrices
that are perhaps singular um the P sudo
inverse behaves like the transpose of
the Matrix so it makes our life a lot
easier Downstream again there is a lot
of linear algebra that gets into the
proofs but at the very heart the
randomization typically boils down to
the fact that this utila is
approximately
orthog the second uh topic that I'd like
to discuss is running time how long does
it take to compute The Leverage scores
obviously you could just compute the
left and right singular vectors of The
Matrix so at worst case scenario it only
takes as much time as the singular value
of composition of a matrix which is
something like order M Square n or MN
squ the mean of the
two it suffices it turns out to just
compute any bases that spans the same
space as the left or right singular
vectors actually those bases are not
unique you can rotate them you still
span the same space so any basis would
suffice this led us to consider the to
the question of can we get good
approximations to The Leverage scores
the answer is yes I'm not going to get
into too much detail on those algorithms
they appeared last year but the bottom
line is that uh by Computing approximate
bases and you do that by an approximate
QR factorization you can get one plus
Epsilon relative error approximations to
The Leverage scores of say tall and thin
short and fat matrices the overall
running time to get those approximations
is basically order ND over Epsilon where
n and D are basically the dimensions of
the Matrix Epsilon is the desired
accuracy there are some Pol logarithmic
factors to consider which come into play
because you can now improve some of
these times to order sparsity using the
Machinery that Michael Mahone was
talking about this morning but if you if
you want sparsity some of the lower
order terms come into play and they
actually mess it up without sparsity
that's the best result we have right now
in the case of square matrices so if you
are looking to basically approximate the
row leverage or column leverage scores
of this m byn Matrix a where now M and N
are comparable uh the direct formulation
of the problem just approximate the
lengths of the the ucan Norms of the uh
rows of the top K left singular vectors
is actually ill posed the problem being
that the K and K plus first singular
value of the Matrix would be identical
and then you could just put in whichever
um Vector you want either the K plus
first one or the K one so you're not
going to get a unique answer and that's
quite a problem
uh you need to look at the relaxation of
this problem and the relaxation would be
that instead of approximating the The
Leverage scores with respect to the best
ranky approximation you're going to
approximate them with respect to some
low rank approximation that is close to
the best rank K1 I'm not going to get
into too much details turns out this is
sufficient for applications um this uh
uh this ends up uh in an algorithm whose
running time to approximate leverage
course in this General case is order ndk
over Epsilon so again pretty much what
you would hope to get Pol logarithmic
factors here you can take advantage of
sparcity but you will Downstream pay
penalties uh when it comes uh to the
lower order terms that are hidden in
this particular big annotation here and
this appeared in papers with joint work
with uh David woodu Malik magdon is RPI
Michael Mahoney here icml and jmlr uh
last
year
okay and for the next 20 minutes I want
to discuss applications how can you use
leverage scores in applications and let
me start with the first application
which is going to be on over or under
constrainted Le squares problems Michael
Mahone actually already discussed some
of this so let me get into some details
here for the special case of L2
regression L2 regression you are given
this design Matrix a over constraint so
you have more constraints than variables
you are looking you have your target
Vector B you are looking
for the vector exop that minimizes the
error B minus a exop okay among all D
dimensional
vectors and under constraint I'm not
going to talk much about but there has
been work there as well very very
similar to the stuff that I'm going to
discuss Mark tiget I think had one of
the first writeups in the area and then
uh in last year's paper in jmlr we uh
treated the subject in detail again
using the more recent advances keep in
mind that typically here there is no
Vector exop such that a exop is equal to
B so you are looking for the best such
vector and there are of course multiple
Solutions because there is a null space
there and you could add anything you
want in the n space still get an optimal
solution uh what you are going to uh do
here is we're going to look for the
minimal L2 Norm Vector exop among all
possible vectors that solve this problem
and that's a problem that has been
treated very very much in numerical
linear algebra we know how to do it
that's a big no no you can solve the
normal equations but this is not
numerically stable you want to have
numerically much more stable methods and
these are exact algorithms they sort of
retain the exact answer uh QR de
composition is more numerically stable
singular value the composition even more
complexity order end is square but
constant factors increase as you move
from less numerically to more
numerically stable approaches this is
the formula for exop it's the pseudo
inverse of a * B pseudo inverse can be
easily computed via the singular value
composition um again this is the minimal
L2 Norm Vector among all the possible
vectors that solve the previous
problem what are we going to do well
instead of working with a full Matrix a
we're going to down sample a create a
sketch of a and work with a sketch same
algorithm I've been talking about we're
going to take the row leverage scores of
a so we're going to take the left
singular vectors approximate the lengths
of the Norms of the rows of those left
singular vectors but of course we can do
it faster as I discussed before so we're
going to create the sketch of call it a
Tilda we're going to keep the
corresponding elements of B so when we
sample a row of a we're going to keep
the corresponding element of B and we're
going to solve the smaller
problem so this is the problem we're
going to solve instead of having the N
byd Matrix a we're going to have the R
by D Matrix a and solve that problem and
it turns out we can prove theorems of
this form we can argue that if you take
X still theop the solution of the
induced problem of the smaller problem
and plug it in back to the original
problem so that's your small solution
you go back to your original data you
plug it in you are not going to beat the
best possible of course the best
possible is the best possible that's the
optimal answer but you're not going to
be much worse you're going to be 1 plus
Epsilon worse this is a probabilistic
result it happens with probability let's
say 90% And you can drive it down as
much as you want by just repeating the
algorithm and keeping the the best
answer how much how big is your sketch
well your sampling complexity is going
to be ordered D over Epsilon and some
logarithmic factors so basically you
need to go of course above d That's the
dimensionality of your original problem
so you need to go above D you need to
keep a number of rows that is more than
D depends on Epsilon the accuracy that
you want to get and downstream there are
going to be some logarithmic factors
that you're going to lose but you solve
a smaller problem you get an answer that
is close to the original one let me say
that we also have bounds for X op minus
xop but this is everything follows from
that it's this particular bond that
makes everything else work
out okay good so that's the first
application very much along the lines of
what Michael was talking about except
that Michael talked also discussed also
generalizations to LP regression which
become a little bit trickier discussed
also generalizations which I find much
more interesting to quen tile regression
which is the thing you would want
actually to do Downstream in practice
and this is the machinery for vanilla L2
Le squares ation problems let's move on
to feature
selection and what we call the CX
decomposition CX factorization the idea
is the following in principal components
analysis what you basically do is the
following you have your Matrix a which
now represents let's say the rows
represent objects The Columns represent
features so you have M objects described
with respect to n features and you
approximate that matrix by a low rank
approximation using the singular value
composition so you express it as let's
say the top K left singular vectors
where K is a parameter that is somehow
chosen based on either some statistical
knowledge about the data or your own
understanding of the data so you take
the top K left singular vectors times
some other Matrix I'm going to call it X
here this is the SVD the advantage of
the SVD is optimality this gives you the
best rank a approximation to a among all
possible rank a mat
with respect to unitarily invariant nors
so mathematically this is great the
disadvantage and let me say that X we
know very well what x is there are many
ways to express it one particular way is
to express S as just the top K left
singular vectors transpose time a it's
basically the projection of a on the
Subspace span by the top K left singular
vectors that's what the best rank K
approximation
is this is nice mathematically but in
practice the problem is that you don't
know how to interpret the singular
vectors so these are features in your
data The Columns in a the left singular
vectors are linear combinations of your
features and linear combinations of
things like let's say you had humans and
you are talking about you know maybe
height weight income and what not a
linear combination of those features
it's not obvious what it means you don't
get actual features when you look at the
left singular vectors you get igen
features you get basically linear
combinations of potentially all your
features so in terms of data analytics
one thing we suggested with Michael
Mahoney a few years ago now was to
replace the left singular vectors by
actual columns basically do feature
selection select a subset of your
features put them in that Matrix C and
then once you have that Matrix C solve
for a matrix X such that a minus CX is
small so CX should approximate a
actually if your target is to
approximate the best rank a
approximation to a CX should be behaving
pretty similarly to a subk the best rank
a approximation to a and here you're
going to get actual columns how many
well you want it to be closed to K as
close to K as possible you're not going
to be able to do it with exactly K and
get a good answer but with a little bit
more than K you'll get a pretty good
answer and of course the advantage here
is interpretability now instead of
having those left singular vectors which
are linear combinations of your data and
it's pretty hard to actually say what
exactly they mean you have actual
features from your data set and
practitioners have a lot of intuition
about the actual features in their data
and perhaps there are much more
interesting things to be said
here what is hard what is easy figuring
out the optimal Matrix X is easy with
respect to unar invariant Norms it boils
down to Le squares so X the optimal X is
the sudo inverse of C * a with respect
to unitarily invariant Norms the problem
is how to figure out which columns to
keep in Sy and that's combinatorial
optimization you could look at all
possible choices you don't want to do
that it takes too much time so what
you're going to do is we're going to get
better algorithms this problem has been
explored quite a bit in the numerical
linear algebra Community it's called the
column subset selection problem you want
to select a subset of columns that
captures the essence of your Matrix
turns out leverage course do the trick
for you if you sample if you just sample
Columns of a let's say we sample C
Columns of a I'll describe what exactly
C is I'll I'll I'll show the formula for
in the next slide so pick C Columns of a
where now the sampling probabilities are
basically the column leverage scores for
a there is a parameter K this parameter
is basically um the it comes from
Principal component so this is your
target rank this is what you're trying
to approximate a with respect to so you
believe that perhaps the top K principal
components is what is capturing the
essence of your Matrix so that's your
parameter K you're going to simple
columns trying to capture the same
Subspace
what do you get if you just run this
algorithm and Sample Columns of the
Matrix features from your data with
respect to their leverage scores you're
going to get a minus CX remember X is
just the pseo inverse of C * a basically
you are looking at the projection of a
but on the Subspace span by The Columns
of C as opposed to the top K left
singular vectors you're going to get one
plus Epsilon close to the best possible
so you cannot be the best possible
you're going to get one plus Epsilon
close to that and the current state of
the art at least in theory is that for
this particular algorithm with
probability 90% again that doesn't
matter you can drive this higher if you
want you will need if you think of
Epsilon as a constant you know getting 1
+ 1 over 100 let's say close to the best
possible you're going to need order K
log K columns from The Matrix and this
actually is a lower bound right there if
you are applying sampling based
algorithms because of coupon collector
problem
issues the running time of the algorithm
is dominated by the time to compute The
Leverage SC and we know that we can do
that in order n dek over Epsilon time
basically and for sparse matrices some
something a little bit faster for which
I'm not showing the exact formula so
that would be the time that it takes to
get feature selection to get the CX
factorization up to to be relative error
close to the best rank
approximation let me talk just very
quickly about one particular application
this application is coming from
population genetics and these are snip
data if you've never heard about Snips
uh there are Losi in the human genome
where we are known to be polymorphic but
they have a lot of structure in those
Losi you basically
are allowed to have only two out of the
four possible Al for example in this
particular Locus you only have a an
individual can be homozygotic in a
homozygotic in G or heterozygotic and
you can be a g or GA doesn't matter we
cannot even distinguish between the two
bottom line population genetics get you
back matrices that are large they have
thousands of rows thousands of
individuals are included in those
matrices and these days 2.5 million
columns are very common matrices very
common dimensions for the number of
snips that I get
so thousands of row 2.5 million columns
um Let me show a much smaller Matrix
because I want to draw it actually on uh
the slide this only has 274 samples
coming from nine populations four
different continents about 10,000 Snips
and again this is about 8 years ago in
terms of Dimensions the advantage is I
can plot it here so this is a raster
plot again every individual there are
three choices homozygotic in one Al
homozygotic in the other Al
heterozygotic so three colors in this r
suffice red green and black and this is
what you get this is what you're going
to get this is what your Matrix is going
to look like 274 rows Africa Europe Asia
and Americas and you are looking at
about 10,000 Snips here if you run PCA
on this Matrix this is what you get the
population separate there are much nicer
plots than this one that I typically
show but for this example this suffices
this is a projection on the top three
left singular vectors of the Matrix so
the left singular vectors are linear
combinations of all Snips linear
combinations of snips are pretty hard to
interpret okay they linear combinations
of LA and The genome biologists have no
intuition about those what they want
they want actual Lo in the genome actual
Snips so we want to find a subset of
actual Snips that basically captures
this kind of information in the left
singular vectors you look at the column
leverage scores these are the colum
leverage scores for this Matrix quite
nonuniform and this is something that we
see again and again I can speak about
population genetics matrices but we see
it in other data as well astronomical
data and so on so forth if you look at
the top 30 outliers here the top 30
Snips they are not outliers they're
exactly what you want to uh SLE this is
how they look like you can see there are
different patterns formed in the
different uh regions of the world and
actually we use those as a panel of
markers of genetic markers that you can
use to at least predict ancestry at a
continental level we have a lot of
refinements of this in various uh
Publications over the years uh and some
more detailed data that I'm happy to
share if you interest
okay my next application is going to be
on solving systems of linear equations
so I talked about Under and Over
constraint Le squares problems what
happens if you look at roughly speaking
the square case so if you now look at
systems of linear equations n byn
matrices very special case here the case
of a laian matrix now the input Matrix
is going to correspond to a graph this
is a nonstandard way I guess or the less
the less standard way to express the
laas of
Matrix the laan is an N byn Matrix if
the graph has n vertices assume the
graph has M edges then the laian is the
product of those three matrices B
transpose WB W very easy to describe
it's the weights of the edges it's an N
byn Matrix of the weights of the edges
I'll assume that all the weights are
positive because I want to be able to
take the square root of w and B is the
so-called Edge inin this Matrix M rows n
columns so the number of rows is the
number of edges the number of columns is
the number of vertices and two nonzero
entries per row which basically indicate
the start and end of each vertex I'm
going to assume undirected graphs here
so it doesn't matter which which vertex
you pick at the start or the end just
arbitrarily pick that and once you have
the Ed in in this Matrix and of course
you have your weights you can get L and
because you can take the square root of
w it's very easy to see that of course
the lapasan is going to be a symmetric
positive definite
Matrix effective resistance is a notion
that comes when you think of graphs as
electrical Network so if you think of a
graph as an electrical Network and it's
a network of resistors and the
resistance at every Edge is basically
one over the weight of the edge then the
effective resistance between two
vertices the effective resistance of an
edge is going to be the potential
difference that you get when you induce
a unit of current on one end you get it
out on the other end so that's a way to
think of graphs now electrical networks
this is the notion of the effective
resistance and numerically the effective
resistance is are the diagonal entries
of this Matrix R here R is an M bym
Matrix defined with respect to the edge
incidence Matrix and the weight Matrix W
okay so it's a formula this is what you
get there's a sudo inverse here the
diagonal LS of this Matrix are the
effective resistances and the theorem
LMA actually it's very simple it takes
only a few L lines to prove um we proved
it with Michael Mahoney a few years back
the idea is that if you look at this
Matrix here the square root of w
diagonal matrix you just take the square
root of the entries times AG in this
Matrix that's an M byn Matrix and if you
look at the r leverage scores of this
Matrix here it's a tall and thin Matrix
then you are getting effective
resistances but so effective resistances
for graphs and the RO leverage scores of
this Matrix here which you can
immediately compute given any graph you
can compute The Matrix not the leverage
scores not the effect not the leverage
scores um give you uh the effective
resistances of the edges why do we care
about effective resistances or leverage
scores in this particular setting
because if you take your graph and
sparsify it with respect to those
leverage scores uh and effective
resistance or effective resistances you
get a sparer laian a sparer graph which
has very nice similar spectral
properties to your original graph this
can be Quantified precisely if you look
at solving I wrote it as a system as a
as a Le squares problem again instead of
writing it as a system of linear
equations because the lassin is rank
deficient uh but if you look at these
two problems this is the original laas
any Target Vector B this is the sampled
laian so you sparsified and you are
looking at only a subset of your edges
and you solve those two problems to get
xopt and exil opt you get relative error
approximations to xopt so by looking at
this sparer laian uh you can get
relative error approximations and that's
with respect to the so-called energy
Norm that's exactly the setting that uh
the celebrated line of work by danman
santang has been using over the past 10
years now and of course there are things
that I'm hiding and this is is how fast
can I solve the sparse problem and you
want to have basically there a
preconditioning chain and you use chive
preconditioners that's the good way to
do it the second is how fast can you
compute effective resistances or
leverage course but for the special case
where your input Matrix corresponds to a
graph the answer to that is that of
course you can use any of the technology
that we have for leverage course but
that's not the best the best is this
line of work by yanis scis Gary Miller
and Richard Pang Fox 20110 Fox 2011 they
argued that you can use graph theoretic
tools L stretch Span in t3es in
particular to get relative error
approximations to the effective
resistances that's the best we can do
they get that in time that is basically
order M the number of edges in the graph
up to PO logarithmic factors our
machinery would have an additional end
there so we don't yet know how to make
our Machinery be extremely efficient in
the case where the input Matrix is a
graph but of course the leverage cores
are a much more General no o they work
for arbitrary matrices they don't have
to correspond to a graph effective
resistances and the low stretch spanning
tree Machinery to approximate effective
resistances for the special case of
graphs we'd like to move this Machinery
Beyond laian move to General matrices we
don't know how to do that yet and it
seems pretty
hard okay in the last few minutes I'm
going to talk about element wise
sampling so I talked about Ros and
columns I talk about I talked about
sampling edges from a graph
what if you want to sample a subset of
elements from a matrix very nice idea
very nice line of work pioneered by
demetrias and Frank maeri back in 2001
leads to additive error approximations
to things like uh the best rank
approximation to a matrix recent
breakthroughs by a number of people at
Berkeley and Stanford people like
Emanuel and Ben and Terry to and Martin
Way right um who basically demonstrated
that from uniform even some examples but
under restrictive assumptions on The
Matrix you can get exact reconstruction
here's the framework so I'm going to
talk about actually the framework that
appears in these papers and quite a few
others the setup is the following you
are given an N byn Matrix a the rank is
row and think of row a small constant
smaller much smaller than M andn
basically okay and it's exact rank you
can't tolerate now errors and so on so
forth it becomes much harder the SVD is
U Sigma V transpose you are sampling
elements of a in r i ID trials where now
you have a probability distribution over
the elements of the Matrix so you are
going to sample in R ID trials with
replacement so you could sample the same
element twice um and in each trial you
keep an element with probability
proportional to this probability
P once you have that you try to find the
Matrix X that agrees with a on your
sample and also minimizes what is called
the nuclear or Trace Norm of the Matrix
you'd really like to minimize the rank
of the unknown Matrix X which agrees
with a on the sample that's what you'd
really like to do that's non convex so
you basically settle for the convex
relaxation and the convex relaxation
here is the sum of the singular values
of X that's the nuclear or Trace
Norm if you if you get P to be just a
uniform sampling probability
distribution you need to assume that
your original Matrix is well behaved
basically left and right leverage scores
are bounded that's the Assumption you
need to make if you don't want that and
this is work with my student AB who
actually is here uh and also a similar
paper I should say has come out from the
math department at UT Austin very very
recently if you are willing to do
non-uniform sampling to figure out
basically which parts of the Matrix are
more influential for something like the
top K Left Right singular vectors then
you can get probability distributions of
this form here so this is a probability
distribution that if you sample with
respect to that with constant
probability you are going to recover a
exactly as long as you sample n plus n *
row Square row is this Rank and think of
it as something relatively small order n
plus n * row Square entries from The
Matrix you are sample nonuniformly you
don't need any assumptions of the
coherence or bounded leverage scores for
your Matrix because of course they enter
here in the sampling probability and
these are Row
leverages the Norms of the rows of the
left singular vectors row leverage this
is column leverage at this point we need
this additional term and we think this
is important this additional term which
is not raow or column leverage seems to
be critical this previous work does not
have it and they seem to be paying a
highly slight a slightly higher uh
penalty in terms of the sample
complexity at least to the best of our
understanding um this result buils upon
a number of ideas uh I want to highlight
two uh first of all we approximate the
product of two linear operators using
element wise sampling very simple result
but seems to be very powerful in this
framework we heavily build upon this
very beautiful paper by Ben w a few
years ago and we also use a very recent
idea by the sopas and Ido Liberty um who
basically suggest that you're going to
sample elements from a matrix with
probability proportional to their
absolute values not necessarily the
square of the absolute values we
actually combine the two here in a way
that I'm not going to describe in detail
okay let me wrap up leverage scores is a
statistic that reveals influential rows
influential counts in your Matrix can
also be used even for element wise
sampling with additional complexities
they're equivalent to effective
resistances if you care about uh graphs
llans additional fact which I did not
discuss at all but you probably um
figured it out from Michael's talk if
you take your Matrix and pre-process it
by pre- or post multiplying by random
projection type matrices you're
basically going to uniformize The
Leverage course and then you can do
uniform samp so one way is precondition
your matrices by basically using random
projection type matrices that wases out
the structure in the leverage scores if
you want actual rows columns elements of
the Matrix you cannot wash it out you
have to compute them and we know how to
do this efficiently so that's it thank
you very
much
yes it's kind of I'm sorry I
couldn't right right
right I'll repeat the question so the
the question is uh basically what are
the eror guarantees that we are getting
are always with respect to Norms and
they are perhaps not with respect to the
underlying combinatorial objects for
example do we pick the same columns as
the best possible CS the C subset
selection problem would be that be a
fair way to frame the
question question
right so so this is this is the linear
algebraic way basically of thinking
about these things so all this line of
work started because we want to
approximate say the left singular
vectors or right singular vectors of a
matrix the natural thing to do there is
Project The Matrix on the approximations
to those singular vectors and look at
how big the residual is and that's
always measured with respect to some
Matrix Norm let it be this the trace
Norm the fenus norm the spectral Norm
it's they are not the only Norms of
interest there are many other Norms that
perhaps are of even more interest in
practice the problem is that they are
not un invariant so they become much
harder to prove things for I think part
of the question which actually becomes
very interesting is that um for example
in the column subset selection problem
we give no guarantees in terms of the
actual columns that we are picking are
we picking the a subset or a superet of
the actual best columns that is much
harder and we have not explored this at
all so I don't know how to move beyond
that one of the reason we use these
Norms is because unitary invariance is
great when you do linear Al
absolutely
absolutely absolutely absolutely
absolutely so this certainly becomes an
issue uh you'd like dependencies that
are logarithmic to one / Epsilon there
are lower bounds that demonstrate uh in
terms of running times typically you'd
like much better dependencies in terms
of column samples you're not going to
get this kind of dependencies you're
going to have this you're going to pay
this penalty just in terms of sampling
so you will need to over sample if you
want to get that close to the best
possible these are worst case theorems
so they work for any input Matrix
a so in certain problems we can get one
over EP it's a matter of fact if you are
looking at the squares of norms you get
one / Epsilon as opposed to one/ Epson
Square so it depends on what is your
exact objective but yeah I mean in many
problems we don't know how to move below
that and certainly let me say again that
these are worst case theorem so in a lot
of practical cases we've seen that K
plus a little bit actually works fairly
well
any
l so so okay so the question is uh
whether there is any link because doing
this line of work and sparse PCA so here
I'm picking actual columns just one or
two right sorry a small number of actual
columns so another possibility would be
to pick a small number of linear
combinations of a small number of
columns of the Matrix that's basically
sparse PCA and that seems to be there
are two extremes one is pick actual
columns the other is pick left singular
vectors which are linear combinations of
everything in between is sparse PCA and
I don't know if these results imply
anything directly for sparse PCA I don't
think they immediately do we've thought
a little bit about this but there are
other results about Spar P don't go
necessarily through this line of work I
think Peter you
yeah
correct correct so that that's a nice
question the question is whether the
statistical properties of uh whether it
is known whether these sketches have
nice statistic properities in terms of
for example regularizing the original
problem basically and uh we have not
explored that enough and Michael Mahoney
actually has a couple of papers where
he's arguing that um subsampling with
respect to labor course I think joint
work with with binu here where they
argue that subsampling with respect to
those leverage scores to a certain
extent can be thought of as regularizing
uh your original problem but again I
think there are many many open questions
here in terms of the exact behavior of
the regularizer there and what exactly
does for your data so perhaps we should
take that one offline and discuss it but
yeah that's that's a great Point
actually at the intersection of
statistics and computer
science thank
you